down three Portland a chance to tie
Willard's 3's good be put it in with one
leg dangling same time is here it's time
how is it even possible to make that
shot under the kind of defense Joe is
fighting through the screen he's off
balance and it is drill and Joe's face
is just classic like watch Joe's
reaction you gotta beat Bryant on the
Utah bench would be smiling if it wasn't
happen against this team 1:12 once well
here is ingles Bogdanovich circling yes
the switch on swanigan Bogdanovich with
24 tonight
Bogdanovich the take in the finish
do you tie back in front
Willard the floater rolls in
it's tied again 42 for Lillard
114 all 37 seconds to go
Mitchell's turn no rebound
good effort by Mitchell Utah another
chance a 17 second differential jae-min
shot clock five to shoot
Mitchell accelerates bad finishes
their spacing is what's opening up these
driving lanes you've got one man to beat
Boyan Bogdanovich did it the last time
with the right matchup and Donovan
throughout the entire season has been
clutch fourth in the league in clutch
points and after he helped win the
rebound back it's Mitchell who finishes
to give you tottaly that is correct you
get the switch because swanigan gets
forced to off the screen by Gobert we
talk often about the screen assists the
floor to make that change
they learn into the backcourt acid in
his hands with Portland down to Willard
splits the D drives and looks like it
should have been a gun 10 it should have
been a goaltend no fall
that absolutely look like it should have
been a goaltend
absolutely 100% was the goal tape
it's the window not wit Voltaire as soon
as it hits the window you can't get it
off that
and here's the issue for everybody
saying why don't they challenge it you
can only challenge that's gonna foul if
it had been called the Volta and not the
other way and for there was contact on
official yep around nice is just this
one hurts if you're Portland because
it's obvious and you've competed so hard
lion not to mention Portland doesn't
have a timeout remaining anyway for a
challenge and now a chance here we'll
see if Utah tries to foul three-point
game Anthony with three seconds left has
to put it up in the corner shot again
[Applause]
Utah
with the help of a horrendous miscall
holds on to a 117 114 victory and you
can see Damian Lillard is rightly irate
as his heroic effort he comes up short
thanks to that egregious miss Fulton he
is she's a hundred percent right he is
100% right I'm gonna compliment Josh to
them they screwed up the officials
absolutely missed his call but he also